my name is Karthik paramasivam I manage
the streams infrastructure at Linden or
the near real-time data processing
infrastructure my me and my teams focus
on our pops-up messaging system which is
based on apache kafka a stream
processing system based on Samsa we also
run it as a service at LinkedIn our
Nearline data pipelines change capture
streaming sequel things like that and
today we're going to explore what would
be the ideal world for a stream
processing you know a world where when
someone tries to build a new app they
don't have to worry about how hard near
real-time processing is and they feel
confident that they can get their job
done in a meaningful amount of time all
right
I do have a lot of material so I'm gonna
go a little fast apologies in advance
for that we're going to talk about the
current state of the Union and then we
get into the meat of the talk most of
you already know we're near real-time
processing is being used today it's used
everywhere practically every vertical
you can think of LinkedIn we use it
obviously for social computing but also
for kind of security monitor application
monitoring you know bought detection all
kinds of things a good reflection of how
this is progressed over the last few
years this is kind of a graph of the
streaming data at LinkedIn and you know
every time we added a few more trillion
messages we thought it's gonna slow down
but turns out it just keeps on going and
yeah it's kind of staggering where it is
right now but you know be expected to
continue to grow I mean just like more
than a petabyte a day and all of this is
also attributed to the growth in stream
processing so this is just a growth in
number of streaming applications at
LinkedIn as you can see that it's kind
of very clear hockey stick growth
and as we are making a platform better
and better we are seeing a lot a lot
more of this coming up and as we do more
stream processing that also increase to
the to the amount of data that we inject
into the system all right so another
reflection of the growth is the number
of technologies out there for stream
processing it's very crowded some are
good at one aspect others are good at
another half aspect the good thing out
of all of this is this lot of
competition and hopefully over the next
few years most of them will mature and
you know you'll be able to get your job
done easily at LinkedIn we use a patchy
samsa which is a top-level Apache
project since 2014 we use it primarily
for its stability reliability and
scalability and we'll talk about some of
the lessons that that we've gotten from
there it's also used by a bunch of other
companies before we go any deeper I
wanted to kind of put a naught
architectural context in around the
stream processing discussion and this is
a fairly canonical architecture you know
practically in every space but similar
to what we do at LinkedIn in essence
there are all of these clients or
devices that are talking to typically a
services layer and the services layer
usually either a bits set of data bases
or it's you know sending some events
into a ingestion system like Kafka turns
out that both of both of these things
are very relevant for for near real-time
processing all their bits that are
happening to your databases at LinkedIn
we have a homegrown database called
espresso we also use Oracle Mexico you
name it these are kind of you know
brought these changes are basically
captured and made available via Kafka
for downstream processing some of the
other databases like cosmos DB or dynamo
DB already have streams offering so you
don't need like another change capture
system you can directly process events
out of them
and yeah and at the end all of this gets
processed by a stream processing system
all right so with that let's get into
what would be the ideal world for stream
processing so in the ideal world as I
see it you know if someone wants to
build a new application they should be
able to kind of use near real-time
processing for doing any kind of
complexity have an application of any
complexity run it at any scale and
that's actually pretty tricky by the way
and we'll talk about why it is process
data from any source you know and
because there are a lot of sources out
there and use their language of choice
and language is a big deal because
depending on the language it could be
very hard for certain people and so the
right language is very important and of
course they want to run it anywhere
right because a lot of environments out
there and you want to run it in the
environment that makes sense for you and
none of this is going to work if you
don't have really awesome tools and may
that make it easy to use so let's talk
about the first aspect which is
complexity what do we mean what I mean
by complexity well so to start very
simple you know in terms of the types of
near real-time processing you can put in
two buckets stateless stateful stateless
is basically message and message out and
I can do bunch of filtering
transformations things like that
stateful is when I get a bunch of
messages in but you don't produce this
message out immediately
you wait for a trigger so you accumulate
some State for a period of time after
which you generate your results so let's
take some examples and talk about talk
about the complexities in each this we
already talked about in a filtering
simple stateless application it's very
easy very easy to code up in any stream
processor out there there's some code
from Sam's are some quotes in embed
let's make it more interesting let's
talk about this data enrichment this
also what I think of as
stateless you get messages in on an
input stream you want to join it with
some database or some you know service
out there and you want to kind of engage
the data and you want to spit it out now
turns out this is a very rich and very
important pattern in in offline
processing batch processing you know
typically people you know ETL are that
all the data into a data lake and now
all the data is there so if you want to
join across many many different data
sets it's very easy
and so you can do a lot of you can
derive a lot of value out of it but in
the near line or the online world this
is actually hard and we'll talk about
why this is hard you know as we talk
about scale as well so you know remember
this line in Samsa we came up with a
concept called
cable in this case we use a remote table
for for accessing our espresso database
and basically the idea is with this
abstraction you should be able to join
your streams with your with your remote
databases or services very easily so
we'll talk a little bit more about it as
we deal with scale in the coming slides
all right stateful processing
aggregations are a good example we also
have stream stream joints which I won't
get into today but if you take this
aggregation example you know you want to
in this particular example we wanted to
count the number of page views per
member in Lindon and count it over a
window of 5 minutes so it's fairly easy
to program this in in the kind of high
level API that we have in samsa but if
any of you use Samsa from a few years
ago we didn't have this high level API
and we had to manually stitch this
together so you know as you can see you
want to kind of group by or basically
partition by member ID then you want to
apply a window you know in this case a
5-minute or tumbling window and then you
want to do a count very easy to express
this let's talk about what are the
complexities here right so of course we
knowing there are different types of
windowing
and you want your stream processor to be
able to support all of them and in an
easy way
there are also triggering mechanisms so
I won't go into the details for but then
you know you know you need to think
about what's the mechanism for windowing
you know you probably have heard about
even time-based processing there's a
there was a paper a few years ago and
have been lots of talks and other blogs
about it
Apache beam is the kind of open source
API from Google which kind of you know
concretize is the human time based
processing model and the the basic
premise is that you want to process data
based on the time when the data was
created not when it arrives at the
screen processor and that's mainly
because there are delays in the pipeline
maybe the device was offline maybe
there's a cross data center replication
delay or maybe you even replay your
streams and if you replay your streams
you want to make sure you budget your
events based on appropriate time so yeah
so beam provides a nice API for this and
in some that we have a beam Runner which
is used for by applications to kind of
do even time-based
processing all right let's talk about
some other other things about that
example that we just looked at when we
do a repartition
based on member ID in this example you
know there are two approaches to it one
is you can do like a classic RPC style
me partitioning and that's what is used
by many frameworks out there in samsara
we use a durable queue in between stages
for doing these shuffle operations and
the advantage of that is that you know
if there is any slowdown in a downstream
operator then it doesn't choke the whole
system it's also important when you do
upgrades it's important that when there
are failures in essence by putting a
queue in in between stages it makes this
whole thing a lot lab a lot more
reliable
let's talk about other complexities
accuracy is a doubt read many times in
many situations you don't really need
exactly ones processing but when you're
doing some financial computations yeah
you know you probably really really care
about accuracy and there are you know
and then you're in this world now it
turns out the exactly ones processing
kind of problem has multiple aspects at
least three aspects I won't go into the
details of each of these I'm gonna skim
through it very fast because we need
like a half an hour talk just on this so
the first aspect is ingestion because
there can be dupes in your ingestion and
if anyone says that hey you know your
stream processor solves or you know all
of these problems and there are no
problem no issues with the ingestion you
know that's not true there will always
be dupes in your ingestions because
there'll be retries the only way to deal
with it is if your client can stamp a
deterministic ID that you then use to d
do pin in your first stage of processing
so there's no way around it the second
aspect is noobs that are introduced in
the during the processing pipeline and
there are multiple approaches over the
course of years the chandi Lamport
technique is very very kind of scalable
it's used by many frameworks we actually
have a design for this in Sam so
hopefully we'll product as its own there
are other approaches as well like
transactions and even dee doop again but
you know I would not recommend them
they're not as scalable as this approach
and also keeps the factoring right the
last part which mostly people forget is
that you're going to put your result
somewhere and as long as you do add
important rights it's all good no
problem and that's what most people do
but yeah if you can't do add important
rights I can't update the same login
then then you have to do some kind of
dee doop again in the database and some
databases support local transactions
like in espresso yeah we do have local
transactions so sometimes we end up
using that all right that was a fast
kind of overview of exactly when let's
talk about skill now you know when we
talk about skill there are actually two
aspects people want kind of I mean when
they think about doing stream processing
app many times their concern is well you
know can-can your ingestion system
handle this kind of scale and or whether
your processing system can handle this
kind of scale so there are these two
have to be dealt with separately so when
it comes to scaling ingestion you know
you're in two categories one is you're
running in the wonderful world of the
cloud and you're using the facilities
available there and if you're using any
of the past services like event hubs or
Kinesis or pub/sub Google pops up then
you don't have to worry about scaling
them you know the cloud provider takes
care of it but if you're running Kafka
on Prem or in the cloud then yeah you
know you you you have to buckle up and
you need to kind of know how you're
going to scale your car for clusters at
LinkedIn you know we you've already seen
the scale at which we operate so we have
to do a lot of work and our teams kind
of constantly improve the kafka
open-source product we have done a lot
of work in the controller and lots of
different parts I won't be able to go
into all of those details due to time
constraints happy to talk about it after
the talk but the basic thing to think
about it is think about it at some point
your single cluster is going to be too
big you know at LinkedIn we run bare
metal right now and it's we don't want
to go usually beyond hundred twenty-five
hundred fifty nodes that means that you
need to have a multi cluster strategy so
at some point you know you're you want
to be able to have a facility value and
users don't have to think about a which
cluster do I go create this queue and
okay my other cues over there and so on
so forth
so we need like a waiver and users just
don't have to think about you know this
kind of scale issues and they just they
create a topic and it just goes
somewhere that's something that we are
currently kind of focused on there are
other a lot of cost considerations scale
is all great and yeah the product scale
so that's good but you have to pay money
for it
and there are lot of optimizations I
just pick one of the big ones that we
are doing this year so the last year in
Kafka like if a broker died they sorry
if a disk died then the broker basically
became useless and so you know we used
to run Kafka with raid on top of Kafka
replication and obviously that's not
very efficient so we did a bunch of work
to make sure that our Kafka broker does
not die if this guy's and now we are
able to kind of run it the the way it
was designed for and this kind of helps
us save a bunch of costs and also
actually gives additional durability
because of more replicas but we only
think about ingestion the hardware costs
are only one aspect the bigger aspect is
your cluster management itself you know
at at our scale this die everyday
machines die every day and you know we
keep expanding shrinking clusters and
and so as a result there's always an
operational problem and to solve all
that we introduce we build the service
called Kafka cruise control it's open
source in LinkedIn skadam and it
basically takes care of self-healing the
Kafka cluster if there any failures it
detects it make sure there are no
anomalies and then tries to do the kind
of rebalancing
in a way that it doesn't saturate the
Nick's saturate the the brokers
themselves an impact live traffic so
there are a few big companies actually
using it out sort of LinkedIn you might
want to check it out I won't go into the
details of this I just kind of left it
here so that later when you look at the
slides if you're interested you can kind
of take a look
alright that was about skilling
ingestion now let's talk about scaling
processing when you talk about scaling
processing obviously you want horizontal
scale all that is great you know but
again comes back to cause you don't want
the stream processing to be like very
expensive so you need to figure out how
you're gonna optimize it and then of
course your scale is limited by your
least scalable component so you gotta
know about what your bottleneck is gonna
be now the triple typical bottlenecks
for the most part our bottle links are
usually around data access IO the stream
processors go really fast but as soon as
they touch some data you know which is
outside of the stream processor then it
all kind of slows down so there's a
bunch of optimizations that we'll talk
about on on how this can be kind of
scalable now sometimes if you can also
be a bottleneck usually it's easy to
solve that you basically add more cores
and I add more containers and like you
know we have some image classifiers
running in Samsa using tensor flow which
you know are extremely CPU hungry and
obviously for some of those cases you
eventually end up with you know better
hardware like GPUs and such um so let's
talk about the problems that we can
solve around data access so data access
we there are two types of problems there
is the problem of accessing adjunct data
as we call it this is the same example
that we looked at earlier about doing a
stream table join basically to enrich
your your events that are coming in now
at scale what this means is that you
want to be able to do your data database
or or service access using async
paradigm so you want to do async you
want to do batching you want to do
caching and you want to make sure that
you don't accidentally dose your
database or your service because other
people might be using it so when you add
all that it becomes pretty hard for
applications to kind of think about all
this they
very worried about you know what they're
gonna break so in the in the really
promote table abstraction that we've
introduced in Samsa the point is to kind
of you know take away this complexity so
that any end users can kind of you know
do this these kind of joints with
confidence and some of these features
are already kind of implemented in the
upcoming release and some of them
hopefully will cannot do it in the
future but the way I see it mostly
stream processing systems will end up
having to solve this problem now
turns out turns out that at some scale
even regardless of what you do in terms
of optimizations if you are processing a
million messages per second and you know
hitting a remote database is just
probably going to kill it
so for these cases you know what we do
is we basically internalize the remote
database into the processing tier by
creating a durable cache we use Brooklyn
which is our change capture product to
do that and we partition the data and
now all the lookups are local this is
this great with because with this there
are no issues of dossing your remote
database now the problem is historically
this was harder pretty hard to wire up
and that's why again the point is we
wanted to make it accessible so the
complexity is kind of taken away so now
with the table abstraction again now
we're able to kind of terminate this
change capture stream into a table and
then you should be able to join with the
table so that all your like lookups are
local alright um that was all about
accessing edging data and data
enrichment the other aspect is like if
you're doing state full processing then
you need to maintain your state right
now of course you can maintain your
state again let's say you're doing a
count you can maintain your count in a
database like any standard database out
there that will work but at some scale
again you want to be able to kind of do
all of these counts and in all of this
state management in a very efficient way
so in Samsa we have this like by default
if you're doing any kind of stateful
operations we use it use rocks DB which
is open source database from Facebook
and we also kind of have a notion of of
a change log to kind of copy the data
over to a durable Kafka topic and that
way the machine dies we can replay and
yeah performance obviously good with
this now when we're talking about you
know stateful applications and
maintaining temporary state one call
that I wanted to make was it only works
if you're doing incremental checkpoints
like at linkedin v some of our
applications have terabytes of state
even if you have gigabytes or a few
hundred megabytes of state if every time
you checkpoint if you're gonna save all
of the data like a full snapshot then
just not gonna scale so this is an area
l exams is always only supported
incremental checkpoints but this is an
area where most of the listening
processors are also I have also added
support and overtime I would imagine
this would be the predominant way of
doing checkpoint now we talked about
local state just some numbers yes a
local say it can be about 100 X 200 X
faster than accessing that remote DB and
obviously latency is also much better
it's always good
yeah but there are you know you don't
hear a lot of people using local state
and that's mainly because the system
needs to make it reliable
so in samsara we've done a lot of work
over the years to make sure that local
state is reliable that is when you're
doing upgrade or if a machine dies you
want to make sure that your least amount
of state moves around right so it's like
a database you know you know your your
processor basically has an embedded
database so you have to do a bunch of
work and Sam's are basically integrates
with yarn when we are running it as a
service so that the state is
what we call host affinity is not broken
so that the containers go back to the
same place where they're running and
start reusing the same state that they
were using before most of the other some
of the other stream processes are also
adding support for this and it's pretty
critical if you want to use local state
alright let's talk about other things
sources so we already talked about
sources like you know the lot of sources
out there the main thing is that your
stream processor should have support for
applicability of sources and and that's
all good but there's one source which
kind of sticks out there and that's a
HDFS and and the point being that many
times you want to take your stream
streaming app and you want to run it as
a offline batch app and maybe you want
to do some experimentation maybe have a
new ml model that you want to try out
with some one day worth of data see the
results and see if it's good before you
push it out to your streaming
environment so there are a lot of these
cases excuse me where you want your
stream processor to run as a Badge
application and for that basically in
samjha the idea is all you do is change
your input to HDFS and the rest of it
just works and that kind of sounds weird
but yeah it does just work the idea is
that Sam still operates like any
streaming application but basically the
stream ends so there's a notion of an
end of stream and when the stream ends
the app terminates the rest of it like
as long as you are doing even time-based
processing your bucketing appropriately
the results are going to be exactly the
same
the other cool thing here is that you
know all the stages of processing are
going on in parallel so it's actually
more efficient alright
so the next one is language language is
very important and yeah you know
everyone has Java API is and when you
think about stream processing is usually
Java but sequel is is probably gonna be
the thing that's gonna the way I see it
transform stream processing make it very
ubiquitous very similar to what hive and
pig did for MapReduce without hive and
pig it was really not very accessible
it's the same thing with sequel so we in
Sam say we support Apache calcite sequel
so it's there's no so we don't have our
own flavor of Seco it's basically what's
used like you know with the practical
side and the idea is that you know with
this you can do all of these kind of
interesting data enrichment applications
and so on so forth very trivially you
can even like for example let's say
there's a database in our case espresso
and you want to kind of get the changes
from there and create like a secondary
index or secondary database create out
update a couch based cache or whatever
it is you can just express it in sequel
very easy right and that just takes the
whole complexity out of the part of the
equation you can also do stateful
processing and you know it's pretty much
the same you can express your windows
and so on and so forth so yeah so
basically I just completely kind of
makes makes the playing field level now
at LinkedIn we we also had a bunch of
you know old hive and pig scripts where
which were being used for our you know
daily dashboards hourly dashboards and
such and we had this need that we won't
do real-time kind of reporting and for
that one of our teams teams basically
converted the hive and pig kind of
scripts into calcite Apache call sites
intermediate representation and from
that we can kind of execute it as a
Sam's an airline app so that's pretty
that pattern is also pretty exciting and
now we are actually evaluating if we can
do this for other
kind of dsls as well like including
sparks equal as well we already talked
about Apache beam and you know beam does
support pluggable engines but what's
very exciting for us for beam is that we
can get the support for python pythons a
big deal for our ML engineers our tool
and tools engineers and with this the
hope is you can run Python based stream
processing apps in Samsa and hopefully
as B Matt adds more languages you know
we'll look forward to supporting more as
well all right the next one is is that
yeah you want to run your apps anywhere
in any environment and that means you
might be running in the cloud you might
be running on Prem
and that means that we won't stream
processing to be offered both as a
library that you can run anywhere or you
you know you want to have a stream
processing service where you can deploy
our apps and that's that's what our goal
has been at LinkedIn we offer stream
processing as a service which means
which means that our application
developers basically submit their stream
processing apps in Java or in sequel and
we deploy it into a yarn cluster we
manage the capacity for the yarn cluster
and leverage all the goodies that yarn
provides us for stateful applications we
make sure we use yarn in an appropriate
way that state doesn't move and we get
hosts affinity for Sam's a sequel this
is a big deal the whole point of writing
something in sequel is that you
shouldn't have to worry about figuring
out what is the container count what's
the memory and every other thing that
that you have to kind of think about for
tuning applications in sequel the goal
is that all of that should be automatic
now this also should be the same for any
Java app so as far as stream processing
is concerned auto-tuning is still like
one of the areas where i've not seen any
stream processor being really good and
hopefully in Sam's also our focuses to
kind of make
this really kind of seamless today
people spend like sometimes weeks or a
month to figure out what's the right
settings in terms of scale course memory
and so on so forth and that that needs
to go away
and yeah you know you want to run your
app anywhere which means you know you
want to use it as a library and you know
when you use it as a library in Samsa we
use ZK zookeeper for coordination but
the rest of it very much is the same you
launch it you run it and yeah and cool
so let's see how are we doing on time
actually there is no time okay good yeah
we are pretty much to the end of it
looks like I went too fast
the last one is yeah you need really
good tools and this is an area where I
think the stream processing ecosystem
really suffers you know if you see that
kind of tools that you have in a lot of
the offline systems it's really really
good
right and this this area is now
improving and you want tools for your
schema management obviously schema
evolution is a big deal
managing Ackles topics managing your job
itself for every streaming job you want
a dashboard where you can see if the job
is lagging behind or is it caught up you
also want to make you monitor your
ingestion systems
so yeah great tools are kind of minibar
and we have a bunch of tools that are
open source for this like Kafka monitor
monitors our Kafka clusters it basically
sends these synthetic events through
every topic not every topic through a
set of topics to make sure the Kafka
systems are monitored borrow is another
open-source tool that is used to see the
application is making progress yeah we
need a lot more tools all right so that
that's kind of the end of the gonna core
presentation on what what I think is the
ideal world this is just a list of open
source projects you know check out the
upcoming release for Samsa which is
Samsa one Oh where some of the things
that we talked about will be available
and we'll have much improved
documentation which I think they have
suffered in the past and yeah you can
check out the Kafka tools as well that
we have let's say out there with that
thank you happened and yeah we are
hiring in case
[Applause]